[Music]
today's question
comes from ronil in california he says
my wife and i are 39 and 40 we make over
230 000 we have 300 000 in mortgage debt
and 500 000 in retirement we plan on
selling our house in the next few months
where we will clear between 700 or about
700 000
in equity we are not happy in our jobs
and do not have passion for the work
we've been doing we want to either
ask for six months unpaid time off or in
the worst case
quit and use some of our savings a
little bit less than a hundred thousand
dollars to travel
while trying to figure out what we want
to do for the next 10 to 20 years of our
career are we being unwise
well you're being very impatient and i
get it when you're restless
you got to be careful because restless
people are looking for diversions this
sounds like a diversion here
we're going to travel and use some of
our savings that we've worked hard for
and try to discover
what we want to do while traveling i
want you to be diligent
because you can figure this out without
traveling i'm not against traveling but
to ask for six months unpaid time off i
do think is unwise
not sure you'd get that that's
essentially fancy form of quitting
uh and i don't want you to quit and use
that savings
when we don't have something to quit to
we want you to walk
to it we want you to walk across the
bridge
the seven stages that i unpack in the
new book from paycheck to purpose
does not require you to take a big leap
and i
i know what you're feeling i've been
there
uh but the reality is you can discover
what that next stage is those next
seasons before
we quit i don't want you to just travel
and go try to find yourself
that's an excuse yeah it's a bad it's an
excuse not to worry about some escapism
that at the end of this you still are
not going to have landed on anything and
then you're going to be screwed
yeah based on what i have done dave and
what i write about we don't just travel
the world and
get quiet under a tree and trust me
yeah that doesn't work no here's the
thing
you need to sell your house sure and you
need to change jobs yes
but you do not need to do your plan your
plan sucks no that's right
you're going to end up in a mess here
dude yeah because they're in great
financial shape if they pay that what
you need to do is you need to spend some
time
go ahead and take your vacation time
sure probably have some sure and use
that time to be introspective
uh maybe a little bit of travel during
some of that spend some money you've got
some money you're not in bad
shape financially but you don't need to
take six months to do this and spend
some time going okay
i'm going to get real quiet on the back
porch with a cup of coffee of a cabin in
the woods
that is 400 miles away 300 miles away
it's not it doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be you want to go to
europe for five months to find yourself
by the way yourself is not in europe
yourself is right where yourself is
could spend 30 minutes dave going to
ramsey solutions.com and taking the get
clear career assessment
then sit alone underneath the tree and
go hey with all these possibilities that
have been pointed out to me
that's that's which one of these things
actually makes my heart come alive when
i think about
doing it and then one more step go spend
time
with somebody who's doing that thing
that career path that you think you want
to do
get that extra level of clarity to say
tell me about the good the bad
what do you love the most what do you
like the least we make this decision
dave
so mysterious and so out of touch
and we've got to simplify it and that's
what we're doing at ramsey solutions
we're saying hey look inward it's not a
way that you're
no you don't need a ouija board yeah you
need to sit down and get clear on where
you're going then get qualified to do
that
follow your steps straight through
that's it and you take that assessment
it's 30 bucks yeah that's a good idea
we'll sell them one of those if i had
their name
if we have their contact stuff we'll
send them one but um
send them a link to do it it's the get
clear assessment it went on today
with the book and it's available right
this second at ramseysolutions.com it's
incredible so if you take that thing
and you figure out who you are then you
start to say okay i'm going to transfer
to this
job in this state and so then i sell my
house and i move
to that job in that state yes i don't
have to take six months off without pay
no i don't have to wander the world
hoping that
that somehow i'm gonna have an epiphany
as i stand at the foot of the pyramids
that's right that's just complete bs
that's right
and not necessary because if you do it
the way that you just laid out dave the
income is not interrupted
right the best part is the income
increases and you're not going to burn
through all the equity in your house and
burn through all your savings trying to
find yourself
while yourself was in front of you all
the time that's really well
that's really true it's just you go out
looking for yourself and by the way
who's with you while you're doing that
yourself
and so you don't need to go looking
they're right there so
you know sit down spend some time maybe
even get with a coach maybe get with a
counselor maybe get with your pastor
uh maybe get with some of your friends
who'll dope slap you into
reality and say no you're not one of
those you're one of these
you're not a tiger you're a koala bear
you're not a koala bear you're a tiger
what kind of animal are you you know
let's figure this out you got to have
people like this sometimes in your life
and so
that's part of what that get clear
assessment will do yeah
this is a gentle dope slap dave yeah but
this is how you do it though because i
mean i've had
have you not had friends that saved you
from yourself i love that you said that
that's
listen that's what you need sometimes
like friends that saved me from myself
half the time it's what we do on this
show is we love you so much we just
reach over and go
as a friend here hold this pop yeah so
um but yeah
it's that's the thing get clear get
qualified get connected get started get
promoted
work through ken's clear steps on this
that it's not just trying to sell ken's
stuff dude
the bottom line is you need a plan and
wandering the earth
is not your plan no um in the name of
i'm burned out and i'm hate my
life and uh that just sounds like you
know i'm 17 years old and i'm gonna go
backpacking in europe for
six months and find myself you're not
17. you make 230
000 a year you have a half million
dollars in your investments
you're not a child anymore my son so um
you're going to function through this
and lay out a game plan like an adult
have a strategic game plan and execute
the plan
flawlessly at the end the plan you're
going to be making more money
in a better situation you're going to
have sold the house you're going to be
in a state
different than california where your new
career is
your whole new life everything about
your new life is going to be amazing
because you game planned it and then you
went and got it yeah and when you travel
you're traveling on purpose right we're
not blowing
money and blowing time we're actually
planning
it don't travel don't don't travel to
hide
no travel to enjoy yeah
don't travel no all of you people do
this they if you
listen if your whole reason to go on
vacation is you can hide from your life
then you need to come home change your
freaking life it's true
there's something wrong with that this
idea it's not it's like some kind of
escapism
yes and of course these people in the in
the
resort world they pander to that that
we're going to have this alternate
reality that we get to go live in for a
little while yes
and then we have to come back to our
horrible life that's that's drudgery
and um dude hey i enjoy travel i like my
home too
you have a pretty great life yeah so do
i i mean you know this idea of vacation
ought to be about
resting and restoring yourself right
yeah
restoration recreating yourself it's
great to resign
you know write that resignation letter
but don't turn it in and go and vacate
and restore
and recreate yourself and come back tear
it up and keep on going but this idea
of coming back to this oh i just got to
make it through to next year's vacation
it's really crazy and i'll tell you
something else about six months of
unpaid
work doing uh six pounds off from work
you hate
you ought to take the rest of your life
off from work you hate right and not be
unpaid yeah that's what we're about here
yeah you need to change
yeah direction yeah get the new thing
get the new thing baby get the new thing
get you a target
if you aim at nothing you will hit it
every time that's the truth
you will hit it every time it's a 100
shot that you're going to miss because
you have no idea what you're aiming at
and other people do ready aim aim aim
oh yeah and pull the trigger that's
exactly wrong oh my god sit around
whine about it pull the trigger so
that's not his problem he's ready to
pull the trigger too fast doesn't have a
game plan so yeah
but but you know you got some people get
paralysis of the analysis on the other
thing right and they can't they can't
move off their butt
they get stuck on their butt so it's um
it's a problem folks you got to think
through these things and lay it out
and then that that's the beauty of a
clear path that's why the baby steps
work that's why ken's seven stages work
this clear path keeps you moving right
along right along right along right
along right along
it's not a treadmill it's a trail blaze